il t'est jamais arrivé quelque chose de
tellement fou que
[Musique]
tu avais du mal à le croire
nous avons développé une
neurotechnologie qui vous permet de
toujours donner le meilleur de vous-même
vous restez vous version améliorée
qui
et pourquoi
c'est la bague
elle te ramène dans le temps de 57
secondes
le 7 ça porte chance
le 15
tu as dévalisé une banque je suis allé
au casino j'ai eu de la chance j'ai une
une combine pour gagner
jumelle Nathalie elle a fait une
overdose des antidouleurs prescrits par
les médecins ça l'a tué je sens une
grande soif de justice sigle de Hanson
est responsable de la mort de milliers
d'innocents il savait que son traitement
était dangereux mais comment éviter que
ça arrive à d'autres vous vous posez la
mauvaise question le vrai défi c'est
voyager dans le temps n'écoutez pas les
imbéciles Franklin parce que l'argent
fait le bonheur
il n'est pas question de mais de ton
rapport au pouvoir
ne laissez jamais la peur mentale
là-dedans vous empêcher d'accomplir ce
qui brûle à l'intérieur j'aurais aimé
faire les choses différemment
cette chose tu l'as utilisé avec moi
on remonte constamment le temps jusqu'à
obtenir le bon résultat
la sacre semble un monde meilleur
il reste plus à 7 ans